this video is made possible by morning
brew morning brew is an email newsletter
sent out every weekday morning you'll
wake up with the most relevant curated
and informative business news from Wall
Street to Silicon Valley delivered right
to your inbox morning brew cuts through
the clutter of business news providing a
quick and high-quality delivery
if you like what we do here at visual
politic for politics you'll love what
morning brew do for business I've been
subscribed for a few months and the
short piece that arrives in my email
inbox every day is genuinely interesting
that is not an easy feat that morning
brew absolutely nail it like I say
whether you want to learn about startup
news from Silicon Valley or investment
news from Wall Street morning brew has
you covered and it's quick and easy to
read with a cup of coffee in the morning
or maybe on your commute whatever you
like quickly link in the description
below to sign up to morning brew and get
the most informative and witty business
newsletter arounds and let's get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
the end of 2018 couldn't have been more
stressful the protests of the so-called
yellow vests have unleashed a wave of
violence and political rebellion in
Emmanuel macron France increasing fuel
taxes to reduce its consumption and also
to increase income has infuriated a
large part of French society so to
reject this measure and to take
advantage and ask for more changes
hundreds of thousands of people
mobilized and took to the streets
wearing yellow vests might think we all
know what came next thousands of arrests
hundreds of wounded and to government
held against the ropes forced to take a
step back or conferred a logistical
setback police here and on down want a
guard and commerce will be betting on
poppy but just a second because in this
video we're actually going to talk about
China and not France China China now
China China and why the hell you talking
about yellow vest Simon what's going on
I don't know
[Music]
well no I haven't lost my mind Frances
incident may have led to a more violent
result than expected but it isn't an
unusual one when the society doesn't
feel represented by its politicians or
believes that their rights as citizens
are being violated protests and
demonstrations commonplace however this
doesn't happen in China which leads to a
few important questions why do we never
see protests like this in China don't
the Chinese have more than enough
reasons to feel dissatisfied and perhaps
the key question here how does the
Chinese government to keep 1.3 billion
people under control without any sign of
discontent all right so right now some
of you probably figure well yes Simon
it's a dictatorship what did you expect
and yes you are right but that doesn't
tell the whole story
there's you know there's always more to
it so listen up
but Chinese non change
despite the reforms which we've already
spoken here on visual politic about 20
or 30 years ago it was expected that
today's China would be really different
many experts predicted that as the
Chinese economy began to prosper and its
middle class grow within a short time
social demands would cause a change in
the political system towards a more open
free and less corrupt system since then
the country has experienced an
impressive economic takeoff and the
Chinese middle class is now composed of
hundreds of millions of people
[Music]
but there's still no trace of riots
okay now yes there have been protests
but there's no real comparison here and
for many Chinese people seeing a
demonstration is kind of like seeing the
beer calling you know it exists but you
don't really want to get involved with
it and not only that but with Xi
Jingping
in power the exact opposite is happening
while Chinese society is experiencing
its best moment in history in economic
terms Xi Jinping is the most powerful
president since Mao in fact he won't
even respect the to mandate limitation
that Chinese leaders had to adhere to
yeah but not the case like that of ever
others in Bolivia
but let's go back to the question at
hand why does the Chinese government
have so much control over everything
that happens and why hasn't this control
suffered any erosion despite the fact
that now the country is much richer and
much more open to the world and also
well what can we expect in the future
well folks there are three key questions
that we're going to answer in this video
mint yes we're going to talk about the
repression machine later but we can also
find some additional elements here so
check it out
[Music]
the pact a recent New York Times article
talked about how the Chinese government
has managed to turn their economic
development into a way to legitimize the
regime and that has a lot to do with the
kind of tacit pact that exists between
the Chinese government and a good
portion of Chinese society it's an
agreement based on the following the
government promises to do what it can to
achieve better living conditions and in
return society or at least the good part
of it doesn't question the government
itself and looks the other way on some
political issues so here's a question
and it's controversial but it's really
topical would you be willing to renounce
civil liberties and political
participation in exchange for an
improvement in your standard of living
well you can leave your answer to that
in the comments below and also in this
survey
[Music]
but don't worry the video is not ending
just yet now this is all very easy to
say but it's not easy to carry out
so the question we can ask ourselves now
is how is the Chinese government managed
to fulfill its part of this bargain well
we've already talked about one of the
issues on visual politic it's in a video
we made about the reforms in the country
that were carried out after Mao's death
to create wealth the Chinese government
put aside economic Marxism and freed the
forces of private enterprise competition
globalism and capitalism
now we've already told you this but
that's not all the other element that
the government has used has been none
other than education and it's not only
just because they control the contents
which we all know see to make everyone
feel like they had a chance especially
the almost 40% of the rural population
that's still mostly poor and this
amounts to more than 500 million people
in the part of China that doesn't have
Shanghai skyscrapers the Chinese
government has created a social
narrative by which anyone who strives
regardless of their economic level can
climb the ladder of social mobility and
reach the highest echelon so how did the
government do that
while they did it through universities
and an access system known as cow cow
the cow cow is a very hard test that if
you pass it guarantees you the
opportunity to study at a higher
education institution regardless of your
income level and your family's situation
because in China unless you have money
access isn't universal indeed it's far
from it each year nine million young
people compete for only tens of
thousands of places and most young
people know that University it can
change their life you could already
imagine the incredible amount of
competition that exists stuff just pass
this one exam but in a country where
corruption in institutions is usually
part of the game a gaucho is seen as an
opportunity relatively fair test that
any student can access that way the
narrative that the Chinese government is
built for years is that in this country
there's full social mobility and any
young person regardless of their
family's income level can progress up
the social scale and on the flipside of
that there's obviously if they don't
achieve that progress it's all on them
cow cow allows the government to say if
you are not successful you can only
blame yourself
you did not work hard enough that is a
very powerful way of governing Yong Zhao
an education professor at the University
of Kansas actually it really isn't like
that the GAO cow is a system that favors
some skills over others and therefore
some students over other students but
the Chinese government has managed to
introduce this interpretation of
equality into their society
[Music]
downtown the Chinese government has kept
Chinese society relatively satisfied
over the past few years
[Music]
the Chinese have seen how their lives
improve year after year and thanks to
the GAO Cowan's a university system that
allows for social mobility everyone
feels like opportunities are available
to everyone in addition the Gao Gao
favours a study model based on memory
and repetition and not on creativity and
critical analysis but something we can
talk about another time but that's not
all so let's continue
[Music]
time perspective the second question
that might explain why the country's
economic growth hasn't been accompanied
by political demands there's a lot to do
with the speed of the changes allow me
to explain
social and cultural changes often happen
much more slowly than economic and
technological changes
[Music]
yes China has experienced a huge amount
of developments but not enough time has
passed for political demands to emerge
this isn't strange if we take a look at
the history of Western democracies both
in Europe and even in America or we can
see the political changes have always
been much slower than economic changes
although they did eventually arrive but
we can't forget the countries such as
Spain Portugal Taiwan South Korea and
the nations of Eastern Europe among many
others suffered under dictatorships of
all kinds until only just a few decades
ago in other words the Chinese are still
moving from poverty to a more
comfortable lifestyle but yes it's
obvious that we can't talk about the
Chinese government's control over its
citizens without discussing coercion so
listen up
[Music]
the power of the force
I think none of us will be surprised if
I say that the Chinese government has
more than enough tools to subdue
protests in the end China is still a
dictatorship that leads in rankings like
these China named world's top
executioner as global rate Falls amnesty
says more people executed in China than
rest of world combined
China is the world's biggest prison for
journalists folks the Chinese
government's control is so great that
busy we all know they've basically been
able to create their own Internet in
China this network is so sensitive that
services like Google YouTube and
Facebook as well as millions of web
pages are simply blocked except for the
use of VPN networks which are of course
illegal the Chinese only see the
information that the Chinese government
allows them to see there's more
it seems that by 2020 the Chinese
government wants to implement a kind of
ranking that will pacify each and every
Chinese citizen based on a lot of
variables credit financial social
political legal etc etc that is the
Chinese government wants to create a
ranking of good and bad citizens maybe
you've seen the television show black
mirror black mirror is almost a reality
China says it's on track to launch its
dystopian scorecard system that ranks
citizens on every aspect of their
behavior by 2020
[Music]
obviously political issues will carry a
great deal of weight so being critical
of the Beijing government could place
you among the most unreliable citizens
which would close many doors to you both
personal and professional which is kind
of terrifying and now you can see the
tools that the Chinese government
employees to maintain its control over
society first the political pact and the
promise of prosperity and opportunity
for all seconds the fact that social
change moves more slowly than economic
change and third the huge amount of
control and repression that the Chinese
government uses these are all reasons
why there are no yellow gusts in China
[Music]
but the question we can all ask
ourselves is will the Chinese government
perpetuate its model or is this country
going to suffer a wave of democratic
change and openness well leave your
answer in the comments below and I
really hope you enjoyed this video do
hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos also don't forget to check out
our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine also this
channel is possible because of our
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please do consider joining them and
supporting us in our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]